meine Identität wurde geklaut und auf
meinen Namen wurden für über 20.000 €
Sachen bestellt ihr fragt euch jetzt
sicherlich wie das geht ganz einfach du
musst einfach nur in Deutschland leben
eine Person die ich nicht kannte hat
mein Geburtsdatum mein Vor- und
Nachnamen und meine Adresse genommen und
konnte auf ziemlich vielen Plattform auf
Rechnung auf meinen Namen bestellen
glücklicherweise wurde dann aber eine
Rechnung von einem iPhone 13 pro nicht
mit in die Lieferung gepackt sondern
separat als Rechnung an meine
Heimatadresse geschickt dann bin ich
ziemlich stutzig geworden und bin zur
Polizei gegangen und nach zwei Wochen
hat sich rausgestellt dass ich Opfer von
Identitätsdiebstahl wurde der
verursachte Schaden beliebt sich auf
über 20.000 € aber davon muss ich nichts
bezahlen ich habe jetzt allerdings in
meiner Stufe Auskunft und Hinweis
hinterlegen lassen dass jemand auf
meinen Namen Sachen bestellt und das war
für mich die Lösung das Problem ist
trotzdem heftig dass es in Deutschland
so einfach möglich ist